[Música]
ah
i
hacen más o menos unos 20 años un día
decide llevar a su hijo a elegir un
juguete
cuando llegan a la juguetería el niño se
encuentra con una estantería donde había
una línea divisoria muy clara entre las
muñecas y el resto de los juguetes
este día el niño se interesó por una
muñeca
casualmente al lado de él había otro
niño que también miraba y trataba de
jugar con las muñecas
este niño lastimosamente reprendido por
su padre el cual le dice que no
sin embargo este niño en un acto de
humildad le entrega la muñeca del otro
niño
que le pregunta a su papá papá la puedo
tener
probablemente lo que al niño le interesó
en ese momento de la muñeca no fue que
fuese un juguete de niños un juguete de
niñas es más seguramente no sabía a
quién podría pertenecer ese juguete lo
que le llamó la atención fue la estética
la estética del rostro y del cuerpo
humano
para entender la estética debemos
conceptualizar la y si lo vamos a
conceptualizar la mejor forma es de
irnos un poco más atrás entonces vamos a
la filosofía a los grandes pensadores
que describieron a la estética como una
disciplina como una disciplina de
estudio una disciplina que estudia lo
bello que estudia la bello dentro del
arte dentro de la naturaleza los seres
que la integran y la percepción que
tiene el ser humano hacia esto que capta
hablamos de belleza también debemos
escribirlas yo como médico les voy a
hablar de la desde el punto de vista de
la ciencia
la belleza es una noción abstracta en
realidad es un concepto evolutivo un
concepto que cambia que va cambiando y
se va modificando con el pasar de los
años
lo que es bello para mí puede no ser
bello para ustedes sin embargo todos
nosotros somos bellos de alguna manera
está en nosotros como desarrollamos esta
belleza
además este concepto y esta definición
está estrictamente ligada a la
alineación de las proporciones a la
alineación de las proporciones sin
perder la esencia natural de cada ser
quién de ustedes
muchas situaciones de la vida en el
ambiente laboral en un ambiente más
informal en nuestras mismas casas cuando
hablamos de estética desde un punto de
vista médico no escuchamos la expresión
quiero envejecer dignamente
de que la escuché por primera vez trate
de encontrar una relación entre estas
dos palabras la verdad nunca le encontré
para que ustedes me pueden ayudar un
poco encontrarla canarias y veamos qué
definiciones nos dan
la búsqueda encontré como primer
definición que dignidad es
circunstancial o que es digno que merece
el respeto y consideración sigo sin
entender la relación entre envejecer y
dignidad vemos luego una segunda
definición calidad de persona que merece
el respeto y le importan los demás
acaso no todos los merecemos importa si
soy joven o cien veces y bueno vamos a
seguir sin encontrar una relación pero
es una expresión muy común
acá por ejemplo para comprobar esto le
muestro dos imágenes de dos señoras dan
los 80 años ambas
señores de la misma edad y así como yo
me lo pregunte cuando hice esta
presentación les pregunto a ustedes
podemos definir cuál de ellos es menos o
más digno que el otro
yo no puedo seguramente ustedes tampoco
porque no los conocemos pero de lo que
sí estamos seguro es que el respeto
merece
hoy además de
quiero envejecer con dignidad se agrega
un nuevo paradigma quiero envejecer con
dignidad y normal normalmente
cuando estamos pensando en normal
aquí nos estamos refiriendo en realidad
que en que estamos pensando caemos de
nuevo en los conceptos relativos en los
conceptos evolutivos lo que era normal
hacen diez años hoy ya no es normal sin
ir más lejos lo que pudo versión pero
seguramente mañana no lo será entonces
quien define lo que es normal o lo que
es anormal
porque en vez de querer envejecer con
dignidad y normalmente no elegimos
envejecer con calidad y placer suena
mucho mejor
deje ser con dignidad y ser hoy la
ciencia nos da una herramienta la
estética la estética como una
herramienta en pro de la salud en pro de
la salud física en pro de la salud
emocional y en pro de la salud social
tenemos a nuestra disposición múltiples
estudios científicos que avalan y la
estética está altamente ligada evolución
de enfermedades y patologías crónicas
y tomaremos paramédicos de muchos del
estudio de la crónica
donde dice que a menudo solemos oír que
la belleza es algo netamente superficial
sin embargo parece que no tanto la
estética en definitiva fue un papel muy
importante tanto en nuestra presentación
personal así como también lo fue de
nuestra fertilidad
además la profesora ha descripto en
diversos y casi todos los libros de
neuropsicología que el 50 por
procesamiento de nuestra corteza
cerebral que de hecho es una de las que
maneja las emociones digitales
de lo que persona y con apps todo el día
es visual como podemos entonces
descartar la importancia la estética del
estudio de lo que invitó y nos genera
placer
y para cerrar la belleza es un instinto
y un instinto básico producto de la
propia evolución los voy a invitar por
un monto tratemos de ir al primer
momento del día hoy en el cual nos
encontramos frente al espejo
tratemos de irak el momento cuál fue esa
sensación la imagen que impactó contra
la retina y bailó en el hipocampo en el
sistema límbico que maneja las emociones
cerebrales
y vi algo no no vi nada
no les puedo casi que asegurar que la
mayoría de ustedes no recordaron lo que
vieron recordaron lo que sintieron
porque la estética es mucho más de lo
que se ve es más lo que se siente
y muchas veces les duele el espejo nos
devuelve lo que nos sentimos
es cierto muchas veces y sin embargo lo
sentimos
la medicina estética y sus avances hoy
nos permiten un rejuvenecimiento mucho
más posible mucho más accesible y con
una mayor adherencia de mayor cantidad
de personas ya que no recibe nos
referimos a procedimientos no
quirúrgicos procedimientos que ya no
involucran un riesgo a la vida del
paciente de la persona la cual quiere
realizarlo y sobre todo tiene la
particularidad de permitirnos respetar
facciones respetar expresiones para no
modificar y resaltar la particularidad
de cada individuo
de qué manera resaltando lo que él
favorece y disimulando lo que nos
favorece tan sencillo como eso
unos casos e incluso me veo obligado a
derivar pacientes derivar pacientes
cuando aquella manchita aquel lunar citó
a que el bultito aquel párpado caído no
era sencillamente algo estético
porque les digo esto porque la medicina
estética y la prevención del
envejecimiento prematuro también salva
vidas
la organización mundial de la salud nos
dice que en los últimos 50 años la
expectativa de vida en nuestro país se
incrementó 10 años es exponencial ahora
pasemos a la aritmética pensemos en que
se puede hacer en 10 se han construido
países completos en 10 en 10 años y se
han destruido otros en mucho menos que
podemos hacer en 10 años
con esta premisa
estaría mal decir que hoy el mundo la
sociedad evolutiva la vida misma nos
obliga al vernos y a sentirnos diez años
menos de los que tenemos
somos obligados a mirarnos y ver lo que
nos sentimos
o podemos dar vuelta a la imagen
como usted no me puede responder se los
respondo yo no no está mal y no nos
estamos obligados sin embargo cuando lo
vuelvan a pensar hay que tener una gran
variable en cuenta
vivimos en una sociedad completamente
hipócrita
que ve lo que no ve que dice lo que no
dice pero aun que siente lo que no
siente
la medicina estética suena distinta
cierto cuando les digo que es una
herramienta importantísima para la salud
física para la autoestima para la
autoaceptación para el empoderamiento
que nos va a llevar a un mejor mejor
desarrollo social y porque no como una
herramienta para la felicidad pero
volvemos acá poco concreto pegamos de
mejorar a un estado de bienestar
prolongado
cuando me escuchan
espero que al igual que yo sientan un
poco de la pasión que tengo por esto
ha sido así como todo durante todo el
proceso que pasa de estar aquí
en este momento vuelvo a revivir todos
los días en mi trabajo dentro de mí
dentro de mi consulta médica que hoy sea
muy drásticamente antes los pacientes
venían a acudir a nosotros por zonas
específicas digamos la puntita de la
nariz caída quiero tener los labios un
poquito más gruesos se me cayó la cola
de la ceja y luego la devolución era con
la misma intensidad tengo los labios lo
más inflados tengo las cejas un poquito
más altas
pero se había empezado a perder la
esencia
y automáticamente dentro de mi práctica
clínica así como también lo puede
corroborar en la práctica de otros
colegas en otros países el motivo de
consulta al doctor medio triste doctor
medio cansada todos los días y llego a
mi caso a mi trabajo que está están
enojadas sin embargo no estoy enojada
entonces la herramienta la medicina
estética también es una herramienta para
alinear atributos emocionales lo mismo
pasa con las devoluciones ahora es me
siento mejor el cambio y la efectividad
y éxito del tratamiento civil y se
reconoce que el paciente vuelve a
ingresar al consultorio con una sonrisa
en el rostro con una vista con una
mirada distinta con los ojos iluminados
diciendo me siento mejor me veo mejor me
relaciono mejor trabajo mejor
la medicina estética entonces no viene
indignar a nadie ni quitarle normalidad
a nadie venimos a hacer una herramienta
para una mejor calidad de vida
al final
carlos le compro la muñeca en línea
no solo le compro yo sino que le dijo
que en la vida él iba a ser libre para
elegir y hacer lo que él quisiese
el niño obviamente se fue a su casa muy
contento con su nueva muñeca
llego a casa
se encuentra con su mamá acostado a una
vez más
triste sin ganas de hacer mucho
y más porque seguís acostada si sos tan
linda como esta muñeca
tenía la goma con la muñeca
sin embargo a partir de aquel día del
niño noto un cambio drástico en la
actitud de su mamá
que se preocupaba más por su imagen
personal que se preocupaba más por cómo
salía por cómo se relacionaba
y el cambio fue realmente importante
estas hermosas señoras smara la mamá del
niño
esta es la muñeca que el niño no sólo
eligió sino que tuvo y que no definió su
sexualidad sino que definió su vocación
este señor mira
y vio al niño disfrutar de su libertad y
ese niño ese niño soy yo hoy frente a
usted
a
[Música]
ah